we begin this hour with a very
disturbing trend in the pandemic
setting up what could become a
devastating fall season on friday
the u.s recorded 194 000 new cases
now we haven't seen a number that high
since winter think about that for just
one second covet hospitalizations are up
three fold from last month
and now internal cdc documents suggest
this
that the delta variant is is as
contagious
as the chickenpox the delta variant now
accounts for
82 percent of all u.s cases and while
the cdc says
vaccinated people can spread it there's
overwhelming evidence the vaccine works
against it here's the data nearly 165
million americans
have been fully vaccinated of that
number only about
0.1 percent or 165
000 people have tested positive for the
virus
and of those positive cases only about
six
thousand have been hospitalized and from
that total
about one thousand patients have died so
for anyone doubting the effectiveness of
the vaccine
that's the hard data here's how dr
anthony fauci explained it
on face the nation if you're vaccinated
you're much much more protected
against getting infected than an
unvaccinated who is completely
vulnerable so you have a degree of
protection
against infection but the critical issue
john
is that if you do get infected the
likelihood of your getting a severe
outcome of the infection is very low it
is much more likely
that you will be either without symptoms
or minimally symptomatic so the vaccine
is doing what you want it to do it's
protecting people from getting sick
you know the evidence cited by dr fauci
is one more reason that businesses
are starting to require proof of
vaccination from staff and customers
those businesses include danny meyer's
union square hospitality group
he is the company's founder and ceo they
operate iconic restaurants like union
square cafe and gramercy tavern in new
york city and elsewhere
the proof of vaccination policy will go
into effect next month
and it applies to all adults 18 and over
children
are exempt children under 18 are exempt
and so are people who eat
outside meyer also founded the burger
chain shake shack but vaccination policy
you got to be vaccinated does not apply
to them they are a publicly traded
company
danny meyer joins us now at the table
welcome thank you good morning
how do you verify that someone is
vaccinated like what what kind of proof
do you want
and how do you confirm that the proof
they're giving you is legit
well there are definitely cards that the
cdc has provided to
show proof of vaccination and there's
also digital
uh proof as well clear has a wonderful
app called health pass which anybody can
get for free
in new york state we have excelsior pass
and we'll take a look at all of those
you intend to be police this very
carefully i mean check ids to make sure
that you're actually seeing
the the card actually it belongs to that
person the most important thing for us
to
check is our staff we care so deeply we
have a
pretty sacred responsibility to make
sure that it's safe to work in our
restaurants
keep in mind when you dine in a
restaurant you cannot wear a mask while
you're eating and drinking
and our staff members don't have a
choice but to serve you and so
if if our staff members are with you for
two two and a half hours
i want to make sure first of all that
they're safe and we're going to do
everything we can
obviously to make sure that those people
who choose to eat with us are also safe
you're getting a lot of applause danny
for doing this many people hope that
businesses will follow suit and follow
your lead but it also comes with some
heat too
are you concerned about the backlash was
this a tough decision for you
to reach it's an easy decision if the
question is
what's the right thing to do it's only a
tough decision if you're trying to take
the easy path
i would say that most people have told
us
this makes me happier to work here
because i know i'm going to be safe
makes me happier to go there yes yeah
thank you
no no no but but finished sorry well no
i just want to say that
i understand that there is great
reluctance on the part of some people
to get the vaccine i don't understand it
personally but
you know what if that is who you are you
will probably choose to dine somewhere
else and we have to accept that i'm
trying to do it without judgment too i'm
really working very hard on not judging
people that don't get the vaccine
and you're not in you're not instituting
it right away why not
we wanted to give both our staff the
opportunity to
to be informed as much as possible and
we wanted to give ourselves the
opportunity to do the same thing
look we don't want to lose one staff
member due to this new policy
and so we're bringing people into our
restaurants on a weekly basis to provide
access to vaccinations we've set aside
spot in our restaurant for that
and we're also bringing in counselors to
help people
who either have been afraid or who just
have been misinformed but here's here's
what i'm most excited about
everyone who works for us also has
family members
and if we can impact even their families
by welcoming their family members in
to get vaccinations as well and or as we
saw
last week when we started this program
we had many many
members of our staff come and get the
vaccination after they got information
and they go back and tell their families
we could have a good ripple effect
i know you call it a policy rather than
a mandate but i found this interesting i
read that before smoking
was you know banned in businesses here
in new york city
you banded in your restaurants like a
decade before the city did right
must have been controversial then you
must have people up in arms like what
the hell are you doing yeah my mom
didn't
like you i'll tell you that but what did
you learn from banning smoking
and how might that apply to saying you
can't come in unless you got a
vaccination
i think when you have something that is
a
personal right like smoking or like at
this point not getting a vaccination
you also have to say okay how does that
personal right
impact other people and what do i choose
for my business
one of the great things about business
in america is we are not government we
are free enterprise
and we have the right to make the kind
of choices we think are right for the
people who work for us
and the people who dine with us and
americas are free
and americans do not have to dine in
restaurants that
that don't welcome vaccine
non-vaccinated people if they choose not
to danny
i'm sorry go ahead so the small guy in
louisiana who's got you know a staff of
five
and a budget not anywhere as big as
yours he might look at this and go
yeah sounds great you're in new york
city but that's going to kill my
business
what do you say to him then he won't do
it yeah danny more than a hundred and
ten thousand restaurants
closed last year in the pandemic how's
the industry doing now
well you raised such an important point
because what i haven't shared this
morning
is that our industry was on its knees
for the last year and a half
in my business we laid off 95 percent of
our staff
at the end of march of last year i don't
want to go back and i know what will
happen
if we do not make our own restaurants
safe and the rates start to tick up
yeah that's when government's going to
step in including they're going to
impose the closures the capacity limits
we do not want to go back to that and
that's why this is so important as well
i hope other business leaders are
listening to you danny i'm very biased
about this particular topic because it's
scary
you have the vaccine and it it affects
other people if you don't want to get
vaccinated fine but now you're affecting
other people
that matters thanks for being here very
much thank